hello and welcome to this video playing
team glute yeah cooked food farm or
something I always screw this up yakov
I'm glute okay so i hope it wasn't too
much on insult with this name screw up
so we have them exchange we here let's
see what he's going for but should be
six that Sam that's an interesting line
I can take here at this only leads to a
pretty dry position where it's not clear
that I have anything 93 is a bit more
interesting as far as I known with this
black player even Bishop g4 as a mover
think f6 I go deform queen to d6 are
home so what am i doing now I have Nyjah
from now let's think about this for a
moment i wonder if i can play something
aggressive reaction in 95 if he moves
the bishop I mean if he wants to avoid
giving me the bishop pair i might play a
4 here like cakes and III i will get
this back this point no yes I'm he has
Queen GLC 5 check yeah let's not do that
d 3 goes f6
hmm interesting I can also just play
defo of course okay let's go d 4 I took
family again taking far too long here
for a simple decision well so here this
is looking like him yeah somewhat
probably a roughly equal ending ending
is wrong I'm sorry we have slightly
simplified position that's what I wanted
to basically say a pawn structure is a
bit better but it's not a big deal
uh-huh that is a little bit surprising
to see maybe he wants to play on the on
the dark squares here but why five and
we'll see if he goes at 5i can take
plane I to you for that cannot be bad
okay and the night isn't doing all that
much anyway so let's get it to stew have
to potentially d3 it's a little bit slow
right it's a bit slow maybe it's too
slow
no well my position is a very solid zone
I don't think he has anything great
available would be surprising at 5y mmm
if I've no I can maybe go F for attack
the night yeah f4 to check the night
what is he doing there Queen to h6 or
something I don't know if it's good
actually I can also just allow him to
take that it's also not particularly bad
tweenage 6 I don't know if this is Queen
23 isn't all that terrible against it
hmm okay
he just goes back okay so the bad
decision never Copa should be six I
guess I wonder if his I shoot my time I
spent too much time on simple decisions
which took me too long and now they are
the interesting moments and they don't
have it the time to play this well now
let's see at scene was a bit worried
about stuff like G 582 was hanging
unfortunately it seems that he just
wants to double I'm sure maybe it's got
something she left to him my background
is a kind of kind of a problem Queen 2 D
3 no 2 D 2
this is hanging time morning I mean
maybe I have to go for activity somehow
I need to play h3 at some point the
point is Sir it's also worth something
here I will keep on coming am I going to
play this badly ok one is going to hook
to you one check check no not good yeah
not good at all okay I started out with
the very okay position I think and then
I screwed it up completely check
necessary loss yeah okay white resigns
yeah this should be okay really I mean
nothing particularly great but it should
be okay and I was really wondering here
yeah that I should simply should not use
like like I did that was just pretty
awful night this is probably already a
bad idea 93 is better yeah yeah this is
a good position here for the piece it
protects the pawns and it also looks at
important squares the line that the
engine gives here for example this this
is kind of okay I guess and still he
goes to be six and i'm rather black here
in this position yeah now that was a
good movie night f6 i didn't really take
this into account or that much one thing
that wasn't clear to me if i can
actually play this this kind of position
strategically this is actually desirable
to expand a little bit but it done now
it weakens the kingside quite quite a
bit
now probably not a good idea now I think
I'm okay with what i did i just have to
play 93 here again I'd run rather black
here I mean stop which gives equal but i
think i'm rather Blackstock gem maybe
some decisions here weren't really great
i mean this is something that i can
certainly play it's not not bad here
Jeff okay you don't necessarily have to
play night duty one that's probably
right but it doesn't doesn't seem bad on
c3 the night is bad anyway so I think
this is this is kind of logical maybe
something else here I mean F where F f4f
what you can certainly and debate this
is something really good I mean I'm not
sure he's threatening all that much if i
take sorry if he takes you four i will
take with the night let's say mmmm let's
say i play something like a three ship
back and route you 10 25 and okay yeah
III is just my a pawneean i want to play
hookie one without the eight point being
a problem but it doesn't seem to be all
that easy hmm yeah like it's totally
okay yeah I am I thought I thought
during the game I'd rather be white in
this position but this isn't true at all
hey is active him I was also thinking
maybe those pieces say I can't win tempe
on them but it doesn't do all that much
so ultimately may be so this position
and then play a play like this
you know it's ok it's ok for black and I
just want to check one thing in the
opening plate this I was thinking about
this move and wondered about it um yeah
I was thinking he might pull back just
to kick me back yet and ask me okay what
what what did this do at the end I had
this f4 idea but this is probably not
good huh I was thinking it takes I then
actually can go d for I was thinking d3
which talk it's not so great but defo is
interesting here just ok ok ok this is
probably an interesting thing then if he
has to if he goes back and I go out for
that then the engine gives 56 I would
just now maybe I can do that huh yeah
it's a wiki Kings gambit in yeah I get I
didn't get this back I don't get it back
ok I decided against this anyway another
alternative could be this aah yeah this
is this is actually better this is
probably better because he cannot cancel
long cause of tween 87 so he probably
will take and go here yeah on them yeah
this is classic ending after 54 I not to
tempt me up on that Bishop to e6 Bishop
to d7 3d 63 takes deform it might still
be ok for black because it's pretty
toothless in general playing the ending
so early ok guys thanks for watching